did he have a funeral john madden or
yes in fact there was a private service
which i uh attended about three weeks
ago
in oakland wow and then there's going to
be a public memorial
at the oakland coliseum on monday next
monday it's 32 dollars and 14 cents to
go to this it all goes to charity and
3214 was the final score of when john's
team beat minnesota in the super bowl
back in 1977. how about that that's john
i mean john was a special man and you
know people who only knew him on
television
he was a larger than life character i
mean it was it was almost cartoonish in
a way you know with the boom and the
thing and the squiggly lines with the
illustrator and dumping gatorade buckets
john was a brilliant man i spent seven
years with him the greatest memories
i'll take is not just being in the booth
with him our dinners talking about
everything he was well read he
understood everything he he was
extremely curious he didn't fly so he he
drove across the country in a bus
he got to know the country and he was
the guy he cut to the chase we're
sitting in new york one night and
and john liked it he loved food he'd eat
all kinds of food
and uh at a nice fish restaurant in new
york and i ordered swordfish and he says
no no you can't have that well why not
he said no no i've got two of my best
friends are commercial fishermen
swordfish they have nothing but tumors
and boils uh are you waiter
get over here
that ended swordfish for me
all right i'm gonna give you a tough
question and you gotta answer uh-oh you
could only let one guy live and work
with him collinsworth or john madden you
can't have both you're on a boat the
boat's sinking you got to throw one of
them overboard and keep one of them
alive
basically that guy throwing somebody off
the boat because because he's out well
there's another man go ahead let's go
ahead and choose
john's not here so i mean he's that's
you've answered the question but i would
probably here's i love both those guys
i'd probably throw collinsworth off
because he'd be able to swim to shore
there you go right yeah